what can i say about kamal ravikant he
is today's modern day philosopher god
king
he has helped millions of people around
the world and he's helped me as well
as you'll find out he is as brilliant as
they come
he is a wonderful writer who works hard
and studies the craft of writing
he is a philosopher and the most
important lesson i think
i will take away and you will take away
from this conversation
is how deep the mind can go especially
when it's fueled with the
self-confidence that can only come
with a form of self-love as kamal
describes so eloquently so beautifully
that it's almost irresistible and
impossible to
not be moved by him his personal story
he is a legend a young a legend
and i am uh so pleased that he spent the
time with me that he did
and you'll see he called it his favorite
podcast ever
um and uh i'm gonna put that on my cv
because that's one of the coolest things
that someone like me can hear who
studies
not but the scientific literature
and not very often the self-help
literature but kamal
uh has really been a force for good in
my life
and i know he will be in yours too so
sit back and enjoy this episode with
none other than
kamal ravikant how to love yourself
like your life depended on it enjoy
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
the way i want to start off our podcast
today is
actually with the end of love yourself
like your life depends on it
uh and and i think the thing that
resonated most to me as a scientist
is actually the in the in the concluding
chapter i don't know i don't know how
you got away with like more chapters
than the bible
but somehow there's like 90 chapters in
it and uh short
and i know there's no slavery there's no
slavery no one's being sacrificed man
but but but all that you know all that
stuff about shellfish and not eating you
know no i'm just kidding
there's no bacon there's no bacon in
this book uh but the end of the book
by uh my guest today kamal ravikat uh
ends with
share what you learn from this take it
away and share it
and it's not based upon like some craven
venal desire to
sell more but i don't think anyone
writes a book like this uh kamal
to make a lot of money it's it's the
experience in it
it's like you know a bible commentary
like nobody writes a bible commentary
to make a lot of money and i feel like
this book it's a self-help book
but that notion at the very end is where
i want to begin this conversation with
you
in that um i think that you're a
scientist i know that you started off as
a research scientist you thought about
going to medical school
you know i think you might be part
jewish because that's that's the way you
know all jewish kids start off they have
to go to medical school
or law school you know if they if they
really fail they could become an
accountant
i suppose but not a scientist but you
started off in science and that's what
you wanted to do
and i want to ask you the word scientist
in the russian language
means someone who was taught it probably
means like a dude who was taught but
let's just say
someone who was taught now to me
interesting
that provides an insight into the nature
of science itself which is that
i was taught brian keating as a
scientist that means i have an
obligation to teach
i want to ask you do you see yourself as
a scientist and what do you think about
this
obligation of teaching that i see you as
a master communicator being one of the
most
foremost explicators thereof so as a
scientist or you know science adjacent
what do you think is the responsibility
of someone with the
tools with the experience with the
mentality that you have
to share with the world you know that's
so interesting using that word
i've never used that word to describe
myself but i was funny enough that you
mentioned this
today like in kamal landing that meaning
kamal's head there's a lot of activity
that happens i'm trying to figure out
life always i'm just trying to
deconstruct life and if you think of my
books those are just like
snatchers and moments of what i
deconstructed about life at that time
when i said life i mean the human self
experience of life and how to
create a better experience of that human
self
and and and i was thinking like look
originally like you know if you look at
the cell or if you look at the
distant nature of evolution it was to to
pass on
to the next it was always to pass on
what did you pass on you passed on dna
it was almost and what is dna dna is
information
dna is literally information that that
dna by itself does nothing
it is just the code you're passing on
you're passing on your specific
code right that's all it was evolution
was passing on the entire reason for
existence was
passing along your code to then further
further and down we are the result of
code that was passed down for
whatever how many millions of years or
if you're biblical how many thousands of
years you know
wherever whatever rabbit hole you want
to go down but then
but then at the same time it's not just
the code of of survival of the code of
the physical building block
there is the there is the code uh the
meme code the knowledge code
like look i was i was actually i'd
google this today funny enough you
mentioned this because i just want to
make sure
in my head you know like uh newton
and newton and calculus right i just
want to make sure
you know just come out make sure you
you're you're correct on this it turns
out there's another person who came up
another mathematician i think who came
up with calculus
yeah right yeah and they were rivals
yeah they hated each other
so so it's like look they passed down
a a code they passed down their
knowledge just like if we were like
it's always dna being passed on which is
just coded knowledge
now it's almost like a responsibility of
us as humans that what we learn
we pass that along so it goes it flows
down
and causes ripple across humanity for
for
till the end of time um because you
existed you were here what was that
extra set of knowledge you
cured that you're passing along it can't
be just your genes or it could be like
the experience the lessons right
absolutely so
that's what my books are that's
literally snapshots and kamal's mind and
like what he's figured out and sharing
it
it's so funny that you say that because
carl sagan so i've got all these finger
pups i'm working on a kamal ravikant uh
puppet but this is oh my god that'd be
awesome i don't know if you recognize
this guy this is carl sagan
and carl sagan was one of the foremost
uh explainers of science in the popular
world
and and he was actually reviled by
proper scientists for being too good at
explaining things
i actually had his widow and his
daughter on
the into the impossible podcast last
year and i'll uh
i'll put links to that in the show notes
perhaps later on but but my favorite
quote from carl sagan
was a book is proof that human beings
can work
magic because a book is written by
someone who may or may not be with us
centuries old
and that book makes you have the
author's voice
in your head it's as close to magic as
humans are capable of so now i say
you know and i'm sure this is true of
the curious kamal podcast but i say a
podcast
is proof that human beings can work
magic look at this we're we're separated
by hundreds of miles you know time
and space we're having an instantaneous
conversation at the speed of light that
will be shared with people around the
world potentially
and uh and here we are and here are your
ideas
preserved with your voice with your
image uh
and and for all time and i think it's
it's it's part of who we are
is the dna of a human being that we are
the only species
that's capable of of doing such a thing
of
passing on our legacy in addition to our
genes
in terms of our memes and our thoughts
yeah and like look what if you know um
newton hadn't passed on calculus he came
up with it great good for me
good for me i figured it out and then
you know it was great
what if einstein did the same you know
didn't didn't do he goes absolutely good
for me i figured it out
what if that's all it was you know good
for me i figured it out right
humanity would be we would still be
banging on caves and bones you know
in some ways but yeah that's that's
that's the you know we have more
sophisticated bones our bones have 5g
have 5g in it but we still stare at you
know pieces of rock silicon
and and glass you know we're not that
far removed but
i want to start also in the in the book
the number there's a lot of numbers in
this book a lot of numerology and
and you and i are engaged in a in a uh
an interesting project to
to have you uh come up to speed on
quantum mechanics and i'm doing that
selfishly kamal i have to admit that in
front of my audience because
i'm interested in knowing what the mind
of kamal ravikant will bring
to a subject that is esoteric that is
arcane but is incredibly important not
only for its practical applications but
for the way it'll change your mind and
i'm so curious
as i did with our mutual friend james
altucher who put us both in touch in
some sense or one another
has influenced each one of us to write a
book i know that i want to get into that
i love him too and uh and i want to say
you know one of his ideas that i've been
working with him is teaching him about
the big bang
and i learned so much from him about his
ideas and he has
and i'm just hoping that you and i can
have a taste of that as well but let's
start with james altitude as a friend of
the show
and the numerology of this book you
basically
have given him so much credit and you
mentioned him in the book uh as
inspiring you to put this on paper not
not just for you but for the whole world
what what do you feel like when you
write a book like this that has impacted
millions of people around the world is
that a burden to you do you feel a
pressure to live up to this expectation
or do you just get on with life
as if it never happened you know it's
it's very interesting because i get
emails every day
right from readers and they're just
heartwarming heartbreaking and the
effect this book is having you know like
like you know i can tell but what it's
coming out a different language
different country because i start
getting invest for that country the
latest has been russia i'm getting all
these emails from these wonderful
russians right
that from like these places russia have
to google and see where it is you know
like it's the big
country and and and it
and but the thing is i take it in i
respond you know sometimes i fall months
behind but i usually catch up with and i
always refer to apologies are
being late and i respond and it's
beautiful it's heartwarming
but then i move on to kamaland you know
which is just what is this whole show
about why am i here what am i doing you
know like the whole thing
it's very hard to walk around just
feeling the i don't
i feel the responsibility when i'm
writing and the responsibility is not to
any
audience it's not to any human being you
know when i wrote that original version
of yourself
i didn't expect it to take off like that
i literally i set out to be
i trained myself to be a to be a fiction
writer
you know i want to write a literary
fiction i want to write the kind of
fiction that
someday professors taught in in college
you know like that level of fiction
right
and yet i ended up writing this little
self-help book right i didn't expect you
to take out it was just purely to share
something i'd learned that was very
important
and i've made a commitment to my friend
and i keep my commitments it's just
you know the classic you're a man your
word is your bond be a man
literally i'm speaking because i'm a
member i consider as a human being yeah
of course
where does your bond keep your word
right and
and so this is something i really firmly
believe it's become one of my
cornerstones of
who i am and so i did it but so
there was no expectation i was going to
go take off or be this big or whatever
right
or even the second version which i put
out which was like okay let me seven
years later really
share all the nuggets i've learned over
time and answer the questions that have
come up
it's it's what it is is it's the
commitment to the work
it's like i have to make this work as
precise and as
honest as like as i am capable as a
human as
myself at this point in time and i do
that obsessively word by word draft by
draft i mean like
through earlier drafts i mean they're
garbage but i let my mind throw garbage
on the page that i can then hammer and
chisel
start hammering and chiseling um so it's
a commitment to the work
commitment to what i'm putting out it's
actually a commitment to the book
not you know and which in itself is a
commitment to the reader
but you if you start doing doing
something for the reader
i didn't know that i would have 16 year
old girls in russia reading this book
you know or like veterans or like this
graham
graham mothers emailing from england or
like these other places and people told
me about
the you know like they stopped incoming
suicide you know the first ever reader i
actually had was it
who emailed me was an israeli guy who
said like the book stopped it from
killing itself immediately i'm like dude
here's my number call me like you know
like
and we met years later in new york city
we were talking to each other like i
didn't expect something
like i've never been to israel i don't
have that that life experience he has
so what i did was i had a commitment to
telling the truth my truth
of what i had learned so that level of
commitment
to to also deconstruct it to deconstruct
it in a way
that that i can wordsmith and get across
that anyone can then apply
you know so if that's that commitment
that i i feel
immense pressure towards but i don't
feel pressured towards how it's gonna
go out of what it's gonna do does that
make sense yeah what i love about it is
that it's not
it's not pure theory it's not only
philosophy there's a lot of philosophy
in it
but it's very practical it actually
outlines as you know i'm a pilot
and one of the things pilots take very
seriously are checklists so we have a
checklist and
there's a saying that you know uh you
you can't there are no old pilots there
are old pilots and there are bold pilots
but there are no old
gold pilots and i think that's a you had
on curious kamal you had a fighter jet
pilot
i'm sure he's not bold and i'm sure he
doesn't rely on raw skill and like
hand-eye coordination because by then
it's too late so you rely
on your process on your procedures on
your training and on your checklist
i see this book as a checklist as a
manifesto
for achieving happiness but before we
move into the book i still want to talk
just one last thing about
you know i don't know you very well but
i can't imagine
the burden uh i i get a burden i get
emails you know once a month
you know from someone in egypt like
here's some jewish guy
you know from new york city and i'm
getting an email from a devout muslim
girl from
egypt and she loved my boy and i'm like
oh that's awesome but
it's about like you know physics and she
has a cosmo but it's not like
i'm going to kill myself and and i do
talk about suicide in my book but
but but how it just seems like this
immense burden
and i know that you're giving gracious
soul but there's a saying as you know
from piloting you know being on planes
you got to put your oxygen mask on first
how do you handle
that i mean you have an obligation to
survive if nothing else
because so many people depend on you but
how do you handle that
a little that's a little hard because i
sometimes forget it's hard but it's also
beautiful
you know like i've gone through things
in life since the book you know that
been very hard like you and i know like
i went for elective surgery and i
they really messed up by the way that's
a whole different story
and i bled to death and washed myself
bleed to that spraying blood out of me
and
and you know the whole experience and
then what they did
the trauma started to do to save me and
save my life and bring me back and then
the recovery which was you know it was
just in every way horrendous you know
like i was
pointing out you know i sometimes i like
reading esoteric tests and mystical
stuff and i was reading in the bible you
know i will put you through the furnaces
so you can be clean and all this
i was like hey that sounds familiar like
you know i felt like i went to the
furnaces
you know and in those moments no matter
who your audience is and what your
responsibility
you have you forget all that and it just
you just have to reach that within
yourself and it comes down to you and
you
um and i mean there was times there
where i wanted to quit
you know i'm very i i um there was a
time there when after
going through that where i was like i
don't think it's worth it i've done my
work i came to this earth
the earth this earth is better because i
was here i could i can
actually say that you know like i seen
the like these books wouldn't exist if i
didn't exist
there you know maybe i've done my work
and it's time to leave
i was at that place last year and
and then you just reach in and you start
did but you know i eat my dog food right
right away you reach in and no matter
what you like
you start you start doing the work you
start doing the work no matter where you
are
you start doing the work um the inner
work it's always the inner work
you know that that expresses itself to
the outer to the outer self
um and in those moments sometimes you do
think huh that'd be kind of ironic
the guy who wrote this book you know
just at some points like [ __ ] it i'm out
well no but i mean you're very candid in
the book about the thoughts that you've
had and
yeah i mean i keep thinking about that
because i know the trauma that you've
endured
recently since the book and the book by
the way has had many incarnations
not just in physical space but in in
spiritual space so to speak
and it's affected so many people but
but again i'm just like yeah this this
this man
he has this capacity but does he have
an infinite capacity and that's that's i
worry for you i'm
again i don't know you that well you
don't know me that well but i'm i'm like
listening to the book reading the book
again and again
and i keep thinking like god i just hope
you know asylum prayer like i hope
you're taking care of yourself and it's
not selfish to do that and so
again you know there's not really much
of a question there it's just
more of an uh of an observation that the
practice is what saves you and it seems
to
keep saving you and coming back you talk
about you know this dovetails with what
i do or you know in some sense as a joke
but like gravity the importance of
gravity
because the gym is actually a very
important thing to you as your physical
soul
and and so forth can you talk about that
uh and and kind of the daily practice
and coming back to it um first of all
are you still doing it despite
all these setbacks and challenges that
you've had or is it just like
you know it it's sometimes you're better
than others no no it's like i learn each
time you gotta do it more
um it's the mental work is more
important than any other work
the inner work and i say mentally it's
more like the heart but i'll let you
i'll i'll answer these in the in the in
the order you were talking about
and you may have to remind me as i go
along it's um
the whole thing about i do feel like i
had something important to give to the
world
when i wrote this book like when i was
especially the second version that came
out last year right
because now i was like already
successful what do i need to put in here
to make it be and i was like i'm going
to make it the end-all
manual and literally no one's ever done
that right step-by-step manual how to
love yourself here you go
it's not bubble baths it's the inner
work you know which may lead to bubble
baths or whatever but it's the inner
work and it's a step by step no one's
ever deconstructed it
your mom your grandmother everybody
tells you love yourself but who
deconstructs it right and so i set out
to do that
and then you become mission driven
because you want to put the very best
you can out to the world especially in a
book you can't unwrite a book
you can't be over someone's shoulder
saying but what i really meant to say in
that sentence was
x or y right and then i also have a
an obsessive commitment to being honest
in my words in a sense not not hey read
my journal feel sorry for me i hate that
kind of writing
i hate that kind of conversation failure
yeah it's more like the lessons why am i
sharing anything you know i shared
things about my childhood
in that book that my mother doesn't know
and i would really break her heart if
she found out
right but why because i had enough
emails from readers struggling with it
and and they thought they were alone so
i wrote shared it to
to show them one how one that did not
alone
and second how i overcame it so that
they realized look
here's this guy he i'm not some
self-help guru i'm not a self-help
writer i'm a writer who wrote self-help
right big big difference yeah right huge
difference
and so and i'm very clear about my
failures so they understand like who i
am
like i'm the guy who came up with this
for myself but look how i struggle with
it
so you don't think you do this and every
you know kamal's perfect i'm not so i
can't do this kamal is far from perfect
come on works on himself that's the only
thing
and that anyone can do um so i had this
obsessive
responsibility to the book that's where
it becomes becomes
because this book is my gift to the
world it's my
and so like so going back to that
surgery experience right when i got to
the hospital
i was in every pain medicine known to
man like when i was in the hospital i
was in iv narcotics
oral narcotics the whole world like i
mean drugged up beyond belief all the
opioids they make
right and this is by the way for my
listeners who might not be familiar
this is someone who didn't drink i mean
you basically abstain from all sorts of
uh
you know alcohol you know i mean i go
through phases i love wine
you know like me too but i'm not i'm not
like i'm just saying to go from like
not drinking you know maybe have a glass
of mango chevits every now and then but
but then to have like morphine drips i
mean that was probably a radical shift
to your system
um well i was in such an insane amount
of pain like of course
no no you could yeah no but what's
interesting is pain you don't even
realize you can
pain can go that far it's like such an
abstract concept
until you're in it you just sort of your
mind can comprehend that that something
like this is possible
that's right um and so i'm thank god for
watching
you know i know i know it's a godsend
literally it's a lifesaver i mean but
here's the thing when they let me out of
the hospital
you know they gave me like the doctor
was like look i'll just keep on
refilling the description i can't give
you a massive prescription like we used
in the old days
but if he literally i remember this
quote if anyone qualifies for these this
year
right she gave them to me and i'm on
them
i'm home i'm in my place in new york i
was staying in new york i was on my
couch in new york city just curled up in
pain and opioid
and opi days for a week right and the
final draft of love yourself was due
this was already in i go to the hospital
mid october
uh the book was coming out and first of
january
and so like the final final like you
can't change a word draft i think was
due in
um something in november but then and
it's the very latest
and so i had a really good draft until
then but i knew there were things that
needed to change and i'd gone for
electric surgery i was going to come
back and work on it none of this was
expected right
so i come out and i start working the
draft and i can't i'm on opioids my
mind's too slippery
and if you read my writing it's written
very simple and that's the hardest thing
to do actually as a writer to write
it's easier to complicate something oh
yeah no to break it down to the simple
principles using the simplest
the words that a child can understand
yeah that's the way the craft comes in
right that's right and so i realized
like while i was doing it my mind was
slippery like i was slipping
slipping and sliding around the words
and i can't be precise then
so i went cold turkey off the opioids
cold turkey
wow i was like and because i was in a
deadline and it was my book it was going
up whether
you know whether i've worked in this
draft or not you know the publisher had
their you know they have their own
harper collins they have a whole
schedule the whole thing they can't
change it's like a big
machinery that's moving so i mean cold
turkey had worked on it
and i would just literally just be
sweating i'd be like working on my
my computer sweating from the pain
trying to get the words precise
word by word my last chance to work word
by word on this book
why you know why did i do that why did i
it was like i would have pain would be
too much i would go curl up and just
curl up in pain
and just like you know i wish i had i
cried because i
maybe crying then would have helped just
kind of like wrote it rolled the pain
through
and then got up back to it in front of
okay pains i've ridden that wave
time to go back to the work went back to
the work because i it was my gift to the
world
so that thing about giving it really at
this point at a certain point you start
working on something and you realize you
bring out to the world
this is my gift and i'm gonna make this
gift damnest
best gift i can and if it takes me
writing pain
that's what i'll go through you know it
was so in some ways it was a gift to me
yeah because it gave me something to get
up for it gave me something to work on
and something go off the opioids you
know one thing i realized about a
weekend
my mind i like the opioids i started my
mind enjoying it
and that's i was like oh [ __ ] i get now
the addiction
yeah you know because it's like you you
know what it is it's not even they
reduce the pain they do but what they do
something else
they make you not care about it and i
was like
it makes perfect sense if your life if
your life is not going well
and you have this thing that makes you
stop caring about the pain and gives you
something like
takes you away and it can be emotional
pain what a beautiful thing why wouldn't
you get addicted to it
you can see why these things are so
seductive and that brings me to
a comment that i noticed from your book
you know there's an old saying
you know hatred is not the opposite of
love
it's indifferent so that you just said
something it's like sending shivers up
my spine because you're basically saying
the drugs are not the opposite of like
love or like you hate them or it doesn't
make you
you know the opposite of pain it makes
you indifferent to pain which is the
opposite of loving it right so which is
why it's so addictive
and you talk a lot in this book about
this particular woman i'm not gonna
i don't i hate it when authors come on
and the podcast tell us the entire
thesis i'm not even saying it so like
you'll sell more books you sell millions
of cups but
the point is is that you have to ex
enjoy this experience because i found it
very few times with books come all
and this i'm commending you uh and
you'll note i do it very rarely you
probably won't find it in any of my
podcasts
but you ever finish a book and you're
like pissed off that you finished it
because you'll never experience the
thrill of finishing it for the first the
first time
and and i think about that with this
book but also how
candid you are and how honest you are
but but i did want to ask you about that
do you agree that the opposite of like
loving yourself would like your life
would it be that
you'd be more scared if somebody is
indifferent to themselves rather than
they hated themselves do you agree with
that old absolutely interesting
that's so interesting i never thought of
it that way but i think in differences
when you stop
caring about life right when you stop
caring about life that's when the
dangers are dangerous
right you're jade yeah when you stop
caring about life is when it just
slides downhill anyway you know
so maybe yeah you're right maybe you're
right because hatred you can pull it out
you can pull out you can like get sick
of it
you know like that that thing in um um
what was the classic movie gone with the
win at the end she goes scott is my
witness i will never go hungry again
you think she'll ever be hungry after
that maybe one or two days here and
there but she's gonna get out of it
that doesn't come from a place of
indifference that comes from a place of
no more
that comes from like okay let the hatred
get to the point where you're just sick
of yourself
and say no more namas you know and as
god is my witness i will get out of this
that
maybe so maybe i think you're right i
think indifference is the actual is the
devil
not the not the hatred yeah you know
right you can use hatred as sort of a
guide or rocket fuel to like
all those people ship around right they
said i was fat when i was in high school
i'll show them and you'll like ruin
yourself um but
but last thing before we leave that the
the book specifically and uh come up
again and again but uh but but
specifically towards this topic of
pain and pain avoidance you know there's
all these economics
you know studies by nobel prize winners
that say you know humans are loss of
verse
you know they don't they'd rather you
know not not win
you know ten dollars than you know
possibly risk losing one dollar you know
it's just an incredible kind of
asymmetry
of pain reception and i wonder if that
you know maybe ties into this thing
about drugs and and this is where i part
ways with
sam harris who we were speaking about
before i started recording
uh you know i have a lot of respect for
but you know him and and people like i
think you're friends with tim ferriss
and you know they they
they promote and extol like psychedelics
and and and
and sort of and i haven't done that much
research on it and people ask me about
it and i just say honestly i'm not that
familiar with it but
i am kind of a uh a drug
non-use maximalist in other words with
my kids and i'm blessed to have kids
you know i really steer them away from
it because
i think in country distinction to what
i've heard sam harris say
that time is not the most precious of
all quantities
nor is attention like we all have time
to watch cat videos i watch a lot of cat
videos
um but how much attention do we have we
actually don't have you know so
detention you can never get back time
you can never get back money you can get
back so i agree money is not the most
precious commodity
but actually it's funny right money's
like just things that once you get that
mindset money's like the easiest thing
in the world
and i want to talk to you about wealth
and the meaning of wealth and the value
of wealth right after this but but
before we do that i want to say what i
think and get your reaction to it
because i know it'll be um it'll be
it'll be you know really valuable for my
listeners to hear
and that is i think innocence is the
most precious
god that's beautiful i don't think you
can get innocence back i think you can
get time back you can get money back
but you can't get innocence back and so
i want to shield my kids from drugs i
want to shield them from
violence i want to shield but i've i've
said this to people
even like world famous neuroscientists
and they're like oh well then you know
they're going to grow up
and be uh and be damaged and be stunted
and i actually said this to
to this uh podcast which i don't
recommend you know to to most of my
listeners to go and tune into my episode
called the drinking brothers
and these guys called it me and
everybody an effing c word and a seeing
f word and whatever
but at the end the guy's like from the
82nd airborne i know you were in the
army as well you've talked about that
but he was saying we went to boot camp
this and we both
probably went to benning oh yeah this is
dan holloway his name's dan
i mean if he was an infantry soldier at
least he went to jump school at benning
it's funny you know just military stuff
yeah i'm sure
and i said to him because he was like no
the most important thing is and i said
like i think it's innocence
and and he just stopped kamal he just
stopped i saw him get teared up
and he goes i've i've been i've gone
overseas i've i've taken a man's life
i've had to do it and i'll never get
that back even though he might have
deserved it or we were in warren if i
didn't take his life he would take my
life
and he'd done it and he's like i can't
ever get that back i can't ever be
the man that i was before i took another
man's life and i feel like if he can say
that
why can't i say to my kids look i want
you to have the first
kiss with your wife or your husband like
i don't i don't feel better like you
talk a lot in this book kamal about
relationships with women and
and and you're very candid and and
because of your candor you're vulnerable
and because your vulnerability the words
penetrate the soul
but for me i i was thinking like i worry
like
are you ever going to be able to get
these women out of your bed are you ever
gonna be
like when you're with when you have a
past history you lost that innocence
and i wonder like can you come clean do
you believe in that kind of redemption
or is it
like a new you a new life is is it
possible to to redeem ourselves once we
and i count myself among it
lose our innocence or is it is it
something you can recapture
that's a hell of a question man i'm
gonna have to think on it because
innocence yeah you're right innocence is
magical yeah i i'm okay i can see as a
parent you never want your kids to lose
their innocence
it's magic it's literally magic because
you can why not look at the world
through filters of magic
um man uh
boy that's that's you got me thinking
all right let's talk about something no
no that's amazing that's amazing man you
got me thinking and thank you for that i
mean
and there's innocence in many things
like i've never killed a human being in
my hands and i hope i never do
there's that kind of innocence i have
and there's other innocence like
with loyalty in relationships or
whatever that i've lost
you know that wherever it wasn't met and
um do you get that back i don't know i
don't think you get it back
um yeah i don't think you get it back
but then maybe that's part of going
through life is maybe losing innocence
and things and then what do you do with
it
you know because i mean you can't be 100
is about everything you might as well
just be in a pod or be in the womb all
your life right
instead then what do you do with that
and you lose innocence in that
lose innocence and this loses we've all
lost in this if you've built a business
if you've built the companies you've
lost your innocence about how
human behavior how people like money
brings out
it's i've actually seen how many brings
out some of it have evolved in
everything in their life but when money
gets involved that's usually where
they've evolved the least
where they will take the biggest and
that's where the ethics will slide
you know so i've lost that innocence you
know but how do i apply it i kind of
more careful about the people i work
with you know so it's like
um yeah so they're different things in
life you're going to lose innocence so
it's like
who do we become what do we how do we
choose to live our life to that
maybe you love through a different lens
not
maybe not an innocent lens anymore but
maybe through a different lens i don't
know
that's a hell of a question man i
usually go don't get stumped
you you really made me think thank you
for this what a gift thank you
well i love your work i love your books
and actually the one thing i
did want to just call to highlight just
to jog your memory because i don't
remember everything i wrote
but there's a really delicious
delightful passage where you talk about
suicide
and you talk you literally use the words
to get out of this suicidal funk
you needed to quote cut a magical
new groove in your life and just as
water erodes rock
and you needed to let that process of
pain
become the redemptive force that took
you away from this and so i do think
it is a form of magic and innocence is
magic but
you know in physics that which can be
transformed into something else has a
symmetry and an exchangeability and i
i think you know it's it's it's that
that we don't know these things it's
that we need to be reminded of them and
maybe maybe these business people that
screw over you know you or whatever
maybe they're also they have a mission
and their mission was to
make make you i don't want to say naive
but less naive or whatever just like
alert you to the nature of human reality
because i do think that you are
you're an optimist i see you as this
like as this uh
a modern-day buddha you know a thin
buddha ripped
jacked up yo buddha but i'm so not the
buddha it's funny though
but uh yeah so let's let's turn to
lighter topics now
let's go let's go to divorce no no i'm
just kidding
nothing worth a california divorce
that's right
we invented the california diverse
that's right that's funny
uh so i want to talk about um you know
just in practical steps
do you feel like the practice is the
capital practice because you know in
other words is this the only practice or
you know can brian keaton come up with
you know enjoy yourself so like you're
in other words is this the one-stop
shopping or do you envision that it's a
framework a scaffolding onto which
i might be able to graft something onto
that actually is my favorite part of
letters from readers is when they tell
me how they're built on it
that makes me happy because look this is
one man's truth one man freaking [ __ ]
out
but it's also who's also an intelligent
man who's who's gone and like
read texts going back thousands of years
on things and realized like there are
certain fundamental human truths and he
just stumbled upon
one as well for himself and he has the
ability to deconstruct and communicate
so he was able to put it out
but it is a truth it is a fundamental
truth loving yourself is the fundamental
truth that
once you once you tap into it does
change things but is
my version the only way no like i mean
there's people i'm sure
like who have been doing this since they
were born or like it's natural to them
or
you can take this and add to it and in
fact i always tell rita's like tell me
what you did
i want to learn from you you know like
this is one man's experience let's make
it a collective experience you know like
build on it you're absolutely right
but what i but what i do say is do this
first
before you branch off get the foundation
right you'll see that this works
and it'll give you the confidence then
to build on it with your own life
experience
it's so funny that you say that come on
because i've been doing this project
called i call it the assayer
uh which is so an assayer is an
old-fashioned
you know scientist who would be given a
piece of gold here's this piece of gold
kemal
and you wouldn't know if it's gold and
so what you would do is you take a
special stone
and that stone was called the touchstone
and the touchstone you'd rub the gold on
it would make a certain mark only if and
if it was
gold and and so the stone itself has no
value
the person who's doing it is not rich
but he or she has the power by this
inanimate
useless inexpensive object to make
people
billionaires millionaires and in so
doing
he had to have a touchstone a companion
object that we call
a scientist calibration so how do you
know you're getting a pound of coffee
when you go down to the coffee shop
well it's calibrated against some
standard and so i view
the practice as outlined and love
yourself like your life depends on it
as a type of calibration touchstone in
other words
it has value intrinsically but it also
has value
in that it can reveal via comparison
additional valuable properties and so i
salute you for that and i by the way i
also think that's true of religion
like if i think if you're if you're you
know if you're considering being an
atheist or whatever
you should at least compare it to
existing religions
if and only if to use it as a touchstone
as a point of comparison
on which you should build upon so
thank you yeah i salute that aspect of
it i want to ask you
do you believe in this saying fake it
till you make it
you know in a different way um not in a
it's more like in a different way not in
the
not in the way you see it on instagram
and all that you know like
or on social media more it's like you
just start
i couldn't be it just stop being it
it almost comes down to the inner self
alice comes down to working on the inner
self so like if you're working on
um even if it's just like we talked
about with money right with wealth i've
noticed it myself if it's just like my
attitude about it changes
you know it's like then then my
relationship to changes and
and my life circumstances with a change
very interesting enough
so in that sense i think maybe be it and
that's a okay that's a very
easy quotable thing to say that i'm sure
you'll make a great instagram call but
then how does one be
it they're right right i hate that [ __ ]
like when was the last time someone's uh
life was transformed an instagram quote
you know like
like what you know i'm it's like
so the the it's the that's what part of
the like by the way that that what i
outlined for love yourself one could
apply for anything because it was about
creating the groups inside
right you can apply i mean i do that i
apply that for other things as well in
my life because i want to like both
it works with this it'll work for others
right i looked at it
and i see you know kind of um are you
familiar with like neural networks
like this this process so um you know
what they do with neural networks is
they flash up
you know to a camera a billion pictures
of dogs and then hopefully the computer
will recognize dogs and so
i kind of feel like part of this message
of your book is
expose your brain to constant signals of
what love
sounds like maybe not what it is but the
more you can do it the ten breaths the
practice the mirror
if you can do that you're training this
three pound
you know squishy computer super computer
and the way that
it has processing things through its
neural network and so
you know it's not even what sounds like
what it feels like you know
we're human we like to think about
thinking creatures we're actually
feeling creatures that the neurocortex
comes in to rationalize what we felt
but the neural cortex occurred to me if
i'm wrong was it was the part that
evolved a lot it all blast
most sophisticated and we think it's the
part that runs the show it's no no
it's the it's the old fire it's the
oldest it's the we go down to the binary
code you know go down that's what's
running the show it's the brainstem it's
the primal self
that's running the show the neuro cortex
is just creating rationality for it
you know that we're not as a dense as
you think we are
you know that's that's the illusion and
if you become honest with yourself i'm
always
i have this thing about in business um
it's like you got to know the rules of
the game you're playing first you've got
to be honest with yourself with the game
you're playing then they know the rules
and that's how you do well right and
and be very honest with yourself not how
you want the rules to be but what the
rules of the game are
right and it's the same thing here it's
like we like to think we're like these
really we're intelligence and we're
rational
we have that word rational right we're
anything but
a human being is anything but rational
there is no objectivity there's only
subjectivity
and and it's just the neurocortex is
that beautiful layer of illusion is that
beautiful matrix that
that the the the the old stem you know
the the old wiring the original
the baked in software is running and the
newer quartz is just creating the
rationalization around it
so we feel like we're actually we're
smart so when you realize that
it's like the whole point of this was to
actually go to the old wire to
cut it through the to the chatter the
neural cortex is also the monkey mind
that creates all the garbage that
creates all the drama that creates all
the
all the drama it comes with a new cortex
right you go you cut through it you go
to the feeling part you cut to the field
you satisfy that you give it what it
needs
and then the neural cortex just
rationalizes that
i mean i'm taking the magic out of this
but really i think that's what it is
no i agree with you actually it
resonates deeply you know
actually physically with the credo of of
judaism
which is uh which is called the shema
which means hear or listen
and that you're not it says like in this
prayer that jews are saying to
themselves three times a day
uh a catechism of sorts and it says uh
do not
uh show you say with your eyes closed
your hands over your eyes
and you say listen and do not follow
after your
eyes and your heart because they will
make you it actually says prostitute
yourself in other words
you will give up everything for looks or
for beauty or for money or
but you won't like give up as easily for
saying
something silently or hearing a voice
like that voice for them yeah yeah yeah
does that the truth it's not the head
it's that that that voice within it
that quiet that quiet voice within
absolutely yeah that's what the truth is
oh my god dude this is this might be my
favorite podcast i've done
like did you get that did you get that
everybody
and i'm singing in the podcast that's on
record that's awesome and you do a
podcast curious kamal i am a subscriber
i love it i leave comments and reviews
and ratings and hopefully everyone will
do that too i i can't wait to uh
every episode that comes out is really a
little a little tiny ear nugget treat
that
i look forward to um so i want to talk
now uh moving into a slightly different
direction
and uh um actually maybe before we do
that so
obviously you are uh you know you're
you're very well known in your own right
you talked a lot about how your father's
influenced you
in a certain way and and obviously you
influence your brother as well
um i don't want to talk about your
brother i don't want to talk about your
father i want to know about your mother
she must be a very special person more
influence our mother was the influence
not our father because
yeah our parents separated when we were
young me too yeah same with me
exactly the same with me and michael but
the influence of the father was more
as a lack of father you know or just the
memories of
childhood father you know mother was all
love
and all sacrifice and in some ways that
was good somebody that was always i can
also see where it went
where heart affected me in ways that had
not been good for me in my as an adult
right because i started to i because she
literally like
raised my brother and nothing we were
not poor we were poor
yeah like we were at homeless at one
point you know and the rest was just
working minimum wage gone all day
you know working one job two jobs my
brother and i my brother and i grew up
in libraries you know which
to our credit made us who we are yeah
exactly you know
i remember one summer i read i counted
like i was i kind of read something like
two over 250 books
it was like i was on a mission you know
like that i just go live because that's
that was our that was child care you
know like
and so all i did was read and then it
was as this was as a young kid
um but what but love we had love
from her and she she was there you know
what in what way she could
and the situation she was thrown into
and there's no no support network
nothing all alone
in a city with two boys two very
independent
very thinking boys right um and i was a
pain in the ass
i was i was my brother was much better
my brother was the good one
i was a pain in the ass i was i was
literally i fully admitted i've
apologized to her many times i was the
pain in the ass
um and and you know so like you
you but it's like so so it was sacrifice
and love
and what i've learned what i realized is
that kind of wired in
in my head to love the love equal
sacrifice
and what i've learned is uh dude that's
not served you
you know love does not have to equal
sacrifice always
you know where i will give up everything
for love and i give myself up for love
and it's like
no you deserve you deserve love without
having to sacrifice yourself
you know but it was like it was it's
very interesting our parents what they
gave us is beautiful but we also carry
we can also we also carry the the other
part with it and that's part of adult is
like
maybe letting go of my innocence and
letting go of my innocence of that and
that's a good thing
that's a good innocence to go give up
that love doesn't have to be sacrificed
love can just be
receiving because i'm just awesome why
not that
what do i have to sacrifice to earn love
you know all right why does love have to
be sacrificed
no that's beautiful man and i feel you
know again you don't know me i don't
know you all that well but but i feel
like i know you so there's asymmetric
knowledge
but same with me my father abandoned me
when i was a young kid my older brother
and i were left to be raised by my
my mother and she had the same thing
working minimum wage supporting two kids
in the 70s it was not super easy
and you know she she bore the scars of
that and painful
divorce and so forth but i always say
i'm thankful to my father i actually
reconciled with my father i if i recall
correctly you never really did with your
dad but now that's another topic for a
different day
but with my dad you know i felt like you
know what
i'm weatherman you know what's the worst
thing so if you have a weatherman
and he's always wrong that's not so bad
because you just do the opposite of what
he says you know you bring an umbrella
when he says it'll be sunny
i felt like that's what my dad was so i
could like just do the opposite of what
he does and i'll be a good dad and i've
heard a kind of joke
said by a psychiatrist that i'm friends
with in ucla named dr steven
marmer and he says your job as a father
is pass along
half of your neuroses to your kids
if we all do that it'll titrate it'll
pipet you know because
it's much better to pass on half of them
than all of them oh okay okay i thought
it said like almost like you have to
pass on no no no no
if you're neurotic i mean i i hear that
i hear that some jews are neurotic i
don't know for sure
[Laughter]
having spent time in new york i've
learned that that stereotype really does
hold
you know like it's it's almost i'm
friends of mine who are jewish i'm just
like
why like you have to explain this it's
really fascinating
but you know the book of the but the
culture and then also the history
and some of it is like yeah you can
understand you can genuinely understand
when you like
you grow up with grandparents who were
always ready to flee yeah
so you kind of unders you kind of get
where this comes from that's right it's
like people say why are there so many
jewish violin players i'm like
because when people are coming after you
with a pitchfork you could carry a
violin better than a piano
so i want to talk about uh about a
different subject now we're going to
pivot radically so
those of you listening out there on
itunes or watching us on youtube
wherever you may be
we're going to pivot radically because i
think you're also a teacher when it
comes to
new technology and in particular what i
want to talk to you about
is is a blockchain and bitcoin and all
sorts of things but before i do that
come on i want to ask you um from a
perspective of
wealth like what is it what is the value
of
wealth i've talked to many billionaires
i've been very blessed and fortunate
to know a bunch of them and i've been
blessed to know people that are abject
paupers
i'm not saying because they're a
billionaire they're good but i've had
people you know extol the virtues of
wealth
in surprising ways on this podcast i've
had about four different billionaires i
don't know maybe you're a billionaire
maybe you're the fifth billionaire
but i want to ask you kamal
philosophically what is the purpose of
wealth
to you you know it's interesting just
this
this guy i've been working with recently
and doing some deals i'm doing
and uh he called me up last week and he
was struggling he was like i gotta ask
you that he's 22. he's like
i'm rich now and i got rich in in crypto
i didn't feel like i got rich by
pushing paper he's like how did you deal
with it when you first got rich
like how do you deal with big you know
getting rich and
like what do you do what happens then i
was like first of all dude
the word rich is a very very interesting
word it's not there's nothing objective
about that word it's a very subjective
word
because you can be around a crew today i
was like look
you you could have a tenth of the money
you have go hang out in bombay
you will feel real and the slums about
me you will feel really rich
right or you could hang out with some of
the crypto crew and you could feel poor
you know with the money you have now
it's a very subjective thing so it comes
down to feeling
do you feel it right it comes out of
feeling it's a satisfaction it's like
first of all do you feel it
because otherwise if you do it around
who you're surrounded by it will always
be people richer than you'll always be
people poorer than you
and that's the lesson i had to learn
because i used to you know i come from
the startup world where
there's stupid levels of wealth you're
free of friends a year later they're
they're like crashing ferraris and you
know when
that they don't even care about and
walking away they almost run your i've
had this happen with like
with a friend like almost ran me over
this ferrari but a year before driving
toward corolla you know like
like i was just like that level of
things happen right and
and you realize um uh
you know it's it's a subjective thing
it's it's a moving target especially the
the groups you hang out in so
um what is go back to the question what
was the question what is it what do you
see as the purpose
of wealth for you personally okay that's
a better question
i'll give you a shitty answer i'll give
you a better answer to your better
question
um the purpose to me of wealth and for
me it's always been it's been a moving
target too maybe that's where i was
getting at you know where i felt
you know i did well and i didn't feel
rich you know where like now i'm doing
well i'm feeling rich
uh what's the difference what is the
purpose of it purpose of it is just
it gives you it comes down to feeling
gives you a feeling of
i can do whatever i want i don't have to
worry for what i want
you know because then at certain point
you get it's just shinier things what
can i get i can get something shinier
or if it's if you're into buying plans i
can get to playing with more seats
that's all that happens that's the only
difference but does that change you
i hope not because if it does you were
damaged in ways that
like you know like yeah money's not
going to help right now yeah
that's what every time you get a more
seed you feel you know it's like
that's not it so i think it gives you a
sense of
um i'm okay it's weird it gives you a
sense i'm okay i can whatever like i can
you don't you know the the i've been a
position in my life ever had to worry
about money and i've had a position in
my life i don't have to remember money
let me tell you it's much better in a
position we don't have to worry about
money
yeah you know because it is a worry
right but the funny thing is
rich people worry about money yeah you
know you know how many rich people you
and i know
that all they do is sit there worrying
about their taxes yeah they worry more
about money than someone who's poor
right you know what i'm talking about
right like absolutely
their mindset if you go into their head
it's a [ __ ] show about taxes about how
they're trying to cut taxes and this is
that
doing trust doing that whatever versus
someone who's just trying to pay the
bills
they worry less about money it's funny
because almost everyone i've interviewed
started off poor
or not wealthy and they became
billionaires and i think those types of
people
have a different approach to wealth and
that it is a tool
it's a and like tools in physics a tool
is something that can convert energy to
useful
work in other words you can do something
with it all of them give back
all of them are philanthropic all of
them see it as a tool and not part of
who they
are yes they enjoy the trappings of it
they enjoy their boats and they're
you know it's funny because i thought of
two different quotes from the movie wall
street that i used on
this guy uh peter schiff and michael
saylor two different sides of the
bitcoin coin
and uh and one of them i said to uh to
peter schiff
you know charlie sheen says to to
michael douglas he goes you know why are
you making all his money
can only water ski behind one yacht at a
time
and and the other guy and the other time
he says a good quote so it's that's true
it's like
you can't have two yachts and like one
one maybe you could with
with your rings you know you're doing
the ring workout you could do two weird
outside
but uh but the other thing he says like
ah he tells his girlfriend daryl and
he's like i'm just saving up
like i'm just living the for the dream
of one day i'll be able to ride a
motorcycle
across china and i'm like you know that
cost like 800 bucks like you could do
that now like anybody could do that
pretty much if they wanted to
so i see it as as yes wealth yeah of
course you know
having had some you know poverty extreme
poverty in my life and then and more
obviously it's easier it gives you
options it gives you as you're saying
it's a tool for what i say is risk
management it's like it allows you to
hedge it allows you to take precautions
it allows you to prepare
but fundamentally my goal has always
been you know bounce the check to the
undertaker because
if you die with wealth i kind of see
these people that die with like millions
even the women in new york city
who died and she left 80 million dollars
to the new york public library whatever
it's like
you know how good she could have treated
people during her life like there are
people starving and like
that's a great point you know it's like
use that before you die
like guy was zero i had the author of
that book he's a african one of the
first african-american like hedge fund
pioneers and leaders bill perkins
he was on the show he actually called in
this guy dan bilzerian he's they're on a
yacht together i know of dan yeah yeah
he's like a crazy guy i don't know i
know his cousin his cousin and i are
friends on our twitter friends
uh but that brings me out yeah to this
point and and i think
it's it's it has a tool it has a purpose
but
um and certainly you know more is better
in a certain sense but but
you know you look at the the extreme
inequalities that there are in the world
and
i just wonder you know does that does it
have an effect on you because also in
judaism
by the way it's you have to give 10
of your income away ever you have to
it's a law
but you cannot give more than 20 percent
away
every year in other words there's a cap
on how much you can get
and that's after taxes by the way so
it's taxes plus 10 percent
a maximum of 20 so you could give away
like 80 of your
of your income but anyway that's because
at a certain level people that are doing
charity
might become convinced of their own
godliness in other words that this
hospital
you know that i'm looking at at ucsd has
a guy's name on it it has erwin jacobs
the founder of qualcomm
you know and i'm looking at i'm like i'm
glad he donated that rather than you
know bought another baseball team or
something
but at the same token it's like you know
he's not god and and there is a value to
wealth and i think the goal should be to
die with zero as this bill perkins book
i want to ask you um now we're going to
switch to actually uh cryptocurrency and
its purpose
another quote from judaism is uh
anyone who is more religious than me is
a religious
zealot and a fanatic and i should not be
like him and anyone who's less religious
than me
is an idolater so as an idol worshipper
is a loser and a fraud
so i feel this way about bitcoiners
versus
ethereum oh god it's a religion it's
worse than relations it's a religion so
give these people guns let's talk about
it let's talk about it i feel like i'm
so sucked down the rabbit hole not like
people are
it's funny because i'll interview
somebody about gold and then the bitcoin
guys will say
i'm a i'm a i'm a gold bug and then i
interview the gold bug and they say um
and he calls me a bitcoin shill you know
it's like
anyway why is it so religiously
overtoned why does it have these
implications of implications of
of zealotry associated with it what is
it about this
little mathematical it's a it's a level
of money involved that
that has that also control
and that's why we talked about business
man people's like least evolved version
comes out
you know you can you see that at least
when [ __ ] hits the fan you can see that
so you can really get to know a person
when she has the fan what the values are
that's right
that's really that's how i've learned
people's real values right
um they can be great until she hits the
fan and then you see ah okay that's what
you're made of because they may actually
be who you think they are
but sometimes you know so it's one very
important lesson i learned was
you know like uh there's a there's a
classic there's a zen story
uh about a scorpion that asks a monk for
for
they're they're the riverbank and he
actually he's
and the monk is about to swim to the
other bank and the scorpion says to the
monk
uh could you give me a ride to the to
the other side and the monk says no
you're a scorpion
you'll sting me and the scorpion goes
well no because then
look we'll both die you know mutual is
your destruction right
so like so like just take this monk's
like okay that makes sense you know do
no harm that's it
has to help life so helping my back you
know they go across halfway goes away
stings the scorpion and he goes what the
hell and
then he's drowning he's dying as they're
scoring i'm a scorpion
you know that's what they do that's one
thing you also learn about people right
and business is like you can't hold it
you can't take it personally
when you when you stop doing that and
that's that's the thing about
remember when i talk about rules of the
game and i've learned about crypto
there's rules in that game and they're
all emotional rules they're human rules
and not rules of
the blockchain right so when it comes to
all this you look at what these people's
incentives what are their emotional need
that they're feeling that they really
need to
take a stand you know often people do
have a movement of any sort and the
crypto is just
the same thing but at the at the heart
of it most of them are not being honest
with themselves which i don't like
in the end it's money they wouldn't be
doing this if they didn't stand to make
money off this if this was purely just
change the world well go we're going to
ngo in africa you want to change the
world you know really want to do
something practical you know there's
plenty of
billions of opportunities things you can
do to change the world right
why choose the blockchain which for most
projects
don't even need a token let's be really
honest right let's i'm not talking about
um right but that's not the rules of the
game the rules of the game are because
there's money involved and people can
get rich really fast really
and there's a lot of unethical players
crypto is full
of crypto brings out the most levels on
ethical is first of all it's global
and anyone can hop in and it's a
get-rich-quick scheme for a lot of
people what do you think that's going to
bring
you know all the people in mlm all the
shady
people on the internet they're they're
all in it right plus good players
there's a lot of good actors people
actually believe in it like a lot of
people who are dick
they creating they feel like they're
really creating the next thing for
they're creating the evolution of the
internet it's like we get to be part of
creating the next thing that brings
people together
that creates power for the individual
right there's also the philosophy
but honestly i'll be honest to say that
that's a minority a fraction of a mind
like a small small fraction compared to
the rest
the rest are in it to get rich yeah and
get rich fast and you see
a lot of scams all the hallmarks of
religion look there's uh
there's like the you know this this
founding origin story
there's this is great i mean if it was a
virgin
virgin they need a virgin involved like
if they had a virgin it would have been
perfect you got satoshi
which who may or may not exist you've
got such a great origin story you've got
to
know
slider man as a sci-fi writer like this
would have been such a great story
i know it's so perfect and then and then
you just have people like just banding
terms around
and like you know thermodynamics of
money and i you know
whatever i i find it kind of funny and
and enjoyable because it's like i talk
from a physics perspective and then
you know they think that oh well i know
the you know i've heard of the second
law of thermodynamics
you know so that makes me a physicist
and now i can say all these big words
like entropy
and and uh you know whatever but but i
find like the the
the vehemence from the you know against
the apostates so there are apostates
just like in a religion you have to have
apostates you can't have religion
there's sacrifices there's you know
there's uh
all sorts of these these characters
characteristics of religion and as i
always say
you know the nobel prize is a type of
religion it's centered on a you know
three-inch golden graven image with a
picture of its founding father alfred
nobel
and these are scientists that are
bending down towards you dynamite
yeah exactly uh financial dynamite is uh
you know
but yeah so i actually want to ask you
about these the non-bitcoin
aspects uh because i actually think
there could be some applications so as
james altitude always
recommends to us we should always have
ideas and those ideas should have sex
and then you produce new ideas and so
one of my ideas is like let's take
blockchain which is really cool as a
cool idea
and science and inventions and
discoveries which is another kind of
cool and let's put them together so how
would that work well
let's say i make a big discovery i
discover a unified theory
of gravity and quantum mechanics which
you and i are studying together
correspondence style via text message
and clubhouse i love it let's
i'm gonna get you your phd kamal you you
mark james didn't think he could get his
phd he's getting it
in cosmology you're gonna get in quantum
mechanics but let's say
i've got the holy grail it eluded albert
einstein
who tried for you know the last 10 years
of his life unsuccessfully
to come up with a unified field theory
uniting the laws of quantum mechanics
and the very small
with the laws of gravity and the very
large he failed but i have come up with
the idea
or or somebody else but i haven't worked
out all the details
but i don't want you come all after i've
schooled you and taught you so much
stuff about
to come and scoop me because then you'll
win the nobel prize that i should likely
so i'll have a second but i'll have to
write another book losing the
nobel prize part two so i think one
interesting thing would be like put it
in a blockchain somewhere put the
discovery somewhere out there
and uh and then use that later on to
show like
actually i had to work out a couple of
extra details but i had the right idea
and i have proof of stake you know that
i actually have the stakes out first
because science you may not realize is
actually extremely compe as competitive
as any
fortune 500 or takeover or vc because
there's
millions of companies right but there's
only one nobel prize and so it's a
conserved monopoly
so i want to ask you like do you see
other uh uh you know kind of beyond like
artwork or whatever i mean i can get i
can talk
i don't think it's heretical the way
that the bitcoin maximalists think to
talk about
nft but do you see a role for it maybe
in science or inventions or patents or
things like
that or that's where blockchain gets
really interesting right um because look
in the in the past
we needed a mailman we needed some sort
of scroll or
scribe we went to and said write down
this record that
now it's official i i paid you you you
were described you were the notary
you know like uh davinci's uh father was
a notary he came from a long line of
notaries right and i was reading his
biography
and turns out they were like really
value respected
upper class because they were the
notaries they were the middlemen who
said
they were the outstanders they were the
assailers yeah but more than that they
were just they're not
they were more like they didn't create
anything right they were just like i'm
putting the seal
that and it's a legit i'm the scribe of
putting the seal and so this is legit
right so that was the that's been all of
human history you know you had to do
that
but what blockchain makes really
interesting is the fact that you don't
need that
the entire community the the the
humanity
anyone running a computer or a phone is
a fraction of that we all become that
together and become a piece of it
that's what makes it really interesting
that truly is the descent it becomes the
internet of anything you know like
i think my brother actually said they
used to call bitcoin the internet of
money right which is really smart and i
think the smartest thing that
that was done with crypto was attach it
to money because
then everyone wants a piece of it you
know you get money involved right
so but that doesn't stop there you can
you can use this technology which is
permissions less you don't need so much
permission
which is trustless you don't need to
trust a middleman you know you don't
need
it's immutable you don't need to like
you know if you do the blockchains right
it's like someone can
change it you know sneak it at night
pull out that piece of paper put in
their piece of paper and now
there goes your proof or steal it it's
gone you know you don't need a safety
deposit box right
so it does that so now you can it's
basically like the perfect record
keeping system
and a record can be a contract a record
can be a financial transaction
a record could be you and i talking you
know it's so
it's that's going to be interesting to
see where this goes and that's purely up
to just
uh the imagination of the human being so
that means you can get this this can go
anywhere
including and i think you're absolutely
right as far as scientific discovery
and also why shouldn't scientists yeah i
think you and i talked about this you it
was you came from you
why shouldn't scientists share the
spoils of the discovery
because right now what are the best
generations of our mind doing
they're google creating a way to get you
to click on more ads
are there hedge funds trying to figure
out that extra fraction of a thing that
they can screw over
someone else because the stock is this
binary
lose so i went like someone's got to
sell me at a cheaper price so i buy at a
higher price right
so um you know the best generation but
best minds of a generation i take it up
by
clicking on ads or screwing someone over
so you can make a fraction of a fraction
of a fraction of
any a piece of stock times a basilian
right that's the best that's the best
so the economic money economic
incentives but what if that person was
doing research and that research they
were able to put out in a way
that's that's like then you could touch
your things that anything that comes out
of it
and they get a percentage of financial
gain what would that be worth you would
you would have in
the people creating world class research
and becoming rich because of it
that would be amazing and that's how it
should be imagine if scientists started
getting rich
and no one tells them no one's ever had
like a vc fund for scientists you've had
people that do you know donations
because you can't monetize
you have to have a money you have to
have a payout at the end otherwise it
because
that's why it's a vc fund a point of vc
fund people ask me what's your thesis on
your vc fund it's return on capital i'll
be honest
that's the rules of the game i've lp's
who put money in my fund because they
want me to
return significantly on capital right
and i deliver
now if you create a way an economic
system that rewards
that creates an outsize outcome and also
a vc funds you get an outsized outcome
like i i passed on a deal um
a couple of weeks ago which probably
would have been a 10x
you know for every dollar you put when
you get ten dollars back i passed on it
because for the kind of work i do i want
like 100 x or a thousand x
right so that's the kind of if you but
what's the scientific discovery work
worth what was calculus worth you know
exactly
i mean like like what is the you know
what is like a new theorem that combines
things or whatever that lets you have
all of a sudden have faster laser or a
laser that can be done with like
one tenth of cost or a few kind of laser
right yeah what is that worth
now if you can tie that to a system
that's recognized
and say like this person and then uh but
you got to get other the problem is this
doesn't just exist
in some blockchain universe by itself
you have to time the real world part
you're trying to economic incentives you
have to get players involved
you have to get universities involved
and they'll license it you know because
normally universities get the
from the patents right or it could be
but if someone was to create that
i think you could create a whole
awareness
and discovery because now all of a
sudden all the greatest minds are that
16 year old kid in his garage who's
trying to figure [ __ ] out
and and does figure something puts it on
there rather than go work at google and
get make you click on ads whenever one
ever 100 times extra
you you know what i mean yeah and then
the incentive that you create the
monetary expense incentive
and we could literally transform like
the case of acceleration
you know i actually think the first step
is awareness because what's happened is
you know so the physics community
invented uh
invented the hypertext protocol that is
the backbone of the world wide web
that was done you know tim berners-lee
was working at cern the particle
accelerator
the transistor was invented by physicist
the
laser was invented for and these are
trillion dollar contributors to the
world economy so
you know email and semiconductor
instructions and and anything that uses
a laser and the global positioning
system
and even your cell phone was invented
you know the only modern invention which
isn't really like
like social networks those weren't like
started by physicists but the
underlying architecture the internet was
but cell phones certainly were
uh they were came out of bell
laboratories the same place that made
the first transistor so
my feeling is that first we need to
start with education because imagine
all these scientists died basically
penniless you know
not that not the ones that certain
because they're working for a company
and the company has
and and someone's rightfully so they're
paying the salaries yeah they're paying
them to work they're paying them
and the output is intellectual property
right so
you know that so that goes to the
company kind of makes sense and they
should actually but they should get a
percentage of it
right in education the ones who are
starving
how do you drive those scientists to go
work in education right to actually work
in a lab
rather than work in in the corporate lab
yeah and i think that's like prestige
that's influence that's
and you know you see nowadays it's just
like well you know
kim kardashian will have a billion
followers and and so forth
uh although you know you only follow one
person
on all of twitter and i'll leave it to
the to the reader or the listener to go
and find out why but
i can always happily explain why okay
yeah the reason why is the rock i
i know but tell us look i'm such
a fan of the rock and for not the
reasons people think i never
watch i don't watch wrestling i've never
seen him wrestle
you know i enjoy his movies i like the
roles that he plays he's very like he
plays a lot of fun roles right but
uh it's because of who he is he he is he
has a commitment to excellence in his
life that is just so rare
that i just really admire that and he
lives it and he's also
he always gives back he's friendly he's
great to his fans
he's great given who he very very
reached in society he is incredibly
humble
incredibly gracious you know
consistently including i know people
have met him
they all say the same thing and so like
i so for me like that's a person like i
would
that's the kind of people i if i'm to
admire people that's who i admire
yeah so that's why so kamal uh
i have a birthday party for a little
girl that i have to go to in a few
minutes and i just want to thank you
kamal for being so gracious
with your time with your mind with your
spirit this gift that you gave to the
world
called love yourself like uh your life
depended on it your other books which
we'll put up
also in the uh in the show notes and
again i just want to wish you
blessings and uh god speed and then i
wanna
also fortify you because the road ahead
is going to be challenging replete with
uh
things like strange languages like
sokatoa
and other things that you will encounter
on my way to
impressing upon you and learning from
you perhaps the nature of true reality
the nature of the observer and i just
can't wait to see where your adventure
story goes from here kamal thank you so
much
oh thank you and i'll tell you one quick
thing is that i was thinking about this
yesterday i was
you know studying trigonometry yesterday
thanks to you and i was like [ __ ] i'm
enjoying this i didn't enjoy math at all
in high school or college it was a chore
you did because you had to to go past a
class i was doing it to pass a class
right and i'm doing it purely out of
curiosity now so like learning about the
you know the sohcahtoa which immediately
came back but just to
but now out of curiosity it's it's
math is a delight it's really
interesting like what a gift you've
given me so thank you
that's right yeah as richard feynman
said calculus is the language that god
speaks and
and i do want you to know that you're in
good hands i'm a doctor
i am i am i'm not going to prescribe you
know oxycodone to you no you have other
doctors that can do that
but i want to say uh that i am
cultivating
and curating the experience that i would
cultivate for
my child or whatever as we go into the
impossible and learn about quantum
mechanics so i'm looking forward to his
exploration
thank you i'm i'm grateful thank you all
right my brother i gotta go put on a
party hat and eat some cupcakes it's
great talking to you
talk to you soon thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
[Music]
[Music]
you